today we're gonna cover regular
expressions hello my name is Richard
Kirchner with the simply learned team
that's WWWF I'd get ahead
what are regular expressions a regular
expression is a set of characters that
helps one identify strings of a specific
pattern so as we dig into this we're
gonna work in our PI charm interface let
me go ahead and pull that up and create
a new project here we are in there and
let's go ahead and call this our e for a
regular expression we'll go ahead and
create that it takes it just a moment to
create that it's kind of interesting
because the history of regular
expression is that it came from a number
of other languages primarily Perl and
people who worked on UNIX way back when
they needed these codes coming in when
they came in to Python and so dealing
with that as far as language and
searching for different expressions in
there that's where it came from and it's
a really good tool for searching through
your strings and doing all kinds of work
cleaning different string formats which
we'll look at in here let's go ahead and
start by creating a new scratch file we
want this is a Python scratch file and
of course in my interface I have the
font of extra-large so hopefully you'll
be able to see that as we type it in and
we'll go ahead and import our e that's
all you gotta do to bring the package in
and it is part of the Python basic
packages so there's no installing of the
regular expression model it's already
part of your Python package let's go
ahead and take a look at some of the
there's like a whole set of code that
goes into string searches and let's take
a look at those in our slides I'll
quickly go through those and show you
what that looks like in code and then
look at some more advanced ways of using
it so some of the symbols for writing a
regular expression is the asterisks the
preceding character is repeated zero or
more times that's what that represents
the plus the preceding character is
repeated at least once brackets the
preceding character is repeated as many
times as mentioned in the braces then
you have period represents a single
occurrence of any character except
newline it's important to remember that
this very common when you're reading
files in you're looking for the carriage
return of the newline character the
question mark preceding a character is
optional
and then we have our tilde which
specifies that the match must start at
the beginning of the string and the
dollar sign specifies the match must
occur at the end of the string the
square brackets matches one out of the
all the characters within the brackets
and we'll see that a lot when we get
into the more advanced setup and then
you can hear it see down here where we
kind of mix and match and it matches any
one character except those not in the
brackets so that's what the last one is
the opposite of the square brackets and
then we have backwards last D matches a
digit backward /w matches a
alphanumerical character backwards last
s matches a whitespace character and
that brings out all the basic ones let's
go ahead and we're gonna squish the code
and kind of stream through these real
quick so you can see what we're talking
about and then we'll look at some more
advanced uses for this so let's start by
putting in a string and we'll just use
one that says ABCD for computer 765
Python 687 kind of just a mixed match of
characters and words going in and let's
take our pattern we'll set this equal to
computer we want to store our solution
and your match because we're looking for
matches equal re dots find all and then
we have our string we're searching we
have our pattern and then we go ahead
and take this and let's just go ahead
and print this out and see what happens
we print a match and let's take your
scratch I'll put a scratch - I'm
starting to have a scratch in there and
you can see down here we get returned
computer not so exciting because it
really doesn't tell us anything that we
need to know other than we have an array
with computer in it so instead of just
looking for a word let's start using
some of those hot characters they used
there's a couple things going on in here
first of all you'll see here we have the
brackets and if you remember from our
slide the bracket means it has to match
one of the characters within it okay so
that's the first thing we got going
there and then with this format you can
do a twosie all lowercase
capital A to capital Z so this this
little part right here tells us that
it's going to be any one of these
characters has to match something in the
the word phrase so we're looking for
those patterns and then we've added
another symbol on here the plus sign and
the plus sign means the preceding
character is repeated at least once and
then finally we're gonna add an R in
front of our string and this is telling
it that it's a raw string and that's
really important because if we had some
character maybe we had underscore in
this is an escape key so if you had a
regular screen this would register as a
carriage return or return line if you
put the R in front it ignores any of
these escape keys so any of these
characters won't affect how it runs if
you put that in there you'll get it if
you don't use a run you have a backward
slash you can have all kinds of problems
so the are just means that this is a raw
string that's all that means
and then we're going to do the same
thing we're going to do a find all
patterns in the string and let's go
ahead and run this and see what our
output is and you can see in here we end
up with ABCD computer and python and
this is what we'd expect because we have
our ABCD here is all in the letters so
there's at least one letter in there
same thing with computer same thing with
Python it makes an interesting question
what happens if I add let's take the
space away and just see what happens if
I do ABCD for so we'll go ahead and run
that and again you'll see that it's only
showing you strings with letters in it
so it gets rid of anything that doesn't
have letters and this is where this plus
sign comes in is it only brings back
letters that are next to each other so
if I have the space itself isn't going
to register and four isn't going to
register if I did something like this
ABCD computer and we run it scratch 2 we
see that's all one word I'm gonna add
the letter the number 4 in there
now let's go ahead and run that and we
run that you'll see again it splits it
it doesn't care whether it's a space a
for a period long as it's not part of
this set lowercase a twosie uppercase a
to z that's what this plus sign does is
it limits it in this case we did our
letters we can also do our numbers 0 to
9 and it's the same way let me go ahead
and run that
and now you see we have the four seven
six five six eight seven so it's the
same numbers on here and I even left
these compress together because four
doesn't have another number next to it
there has to be at least two in a row
it's gonna register as just four but you
can see here four seven six five six
eight seven
so we've now pulled all the numbers out
of there and then if we wanted to do
both letters are both words and numbers
we can do this two ways if you combine
what we just did on this and to capital
C we can run this and you'll see we now
have ABCD for computer seven six five
Python six eight seven
now another format you can do with this
to get the same answer will look more
like this where we have a period we have
our brackets with not space and a plus
sign afterward and if you remember the
period represents a single occurrence of
any character except newline and then we
have specifies at the match muster at
the beginning of the string and if you
do it till the dot dot matches any one
character except those not in the
brackets this is actually different one
what I meant is this one right here
specifies the match must start at the
beginning of the string so we're looking
at a string that has characters at the
beginning and let's go ahead and go back
over there and take a look at that
syntax so we have our period our
brackets or a little caret in the plus
sign and let's go ahead and run this and
we get the same answer but notice a
change here this answer is slightly
different than the last one this one has
the space preceding it so it says hey if
we don't have characters that are
matching when they stop matching at the
end that's when we have the break and we
can see this if we do let's do this for
a and just run that you can see that
it's looking for those white spaces to
split things apart and if we take the a
out let's just out of curiosity what
happens when I do
ABCD for you'll see that it now just
groups that together as one word and we
would have gotten the same thing if we
had done this with the a through Z
capital A through capital Z set up the
difference is is this now puts the
whitespace at the beginning because
that's how this is looking for that
blank space there I'm getting a little
tired of this string of data so let's
create a slightly different string this
case we're using if you do this 3c
brackets after string it then registers
this all as part of the string so it
includes the line carried return here
banana orange peach avocado cherries
we'll go a little fruity on you switch
up from just random words and let's take
our print em I'll just iterate through
match so three four in match of course
indent the print this is just gonna
print them each as a single line as
opposed to printing them like we have
down here as an array that's all that's
doing just changing that up a little bit
I have a little fun here and let's take
our pattern we're gonna do our string
our exact string and on this we're just
gonna do dot star s so what the heck is
going on here
so we have the dot represents a single
occurrence of any character except
newline preceding character is repeated
zero or more times and then we hit the
letter s so we do this let me go ahead
and run this and let's see what comes
out and we'll end up with cherries why
cuz we're looking for any character does
not a carriage return it has whatever
character is in front of it one or more
characters in front of it this is a
wildcards asterisk is always a wild-card
and then s we're looking for something
that ends in s basically says how many
of our characters that are is not a
carriage return ending in s and if you
look at the words the only one we have
that follows that as cherries so we run
this we end up with cherries and then
we're gonna change this up we're gonna
use word boundaries and let's go back
and remember what the forward or
backward slash B stands for so we're
looking for boundaries and then we did
all the vowels AEIOU I'm a holder and
then the plus side and let's go ahead
and run that in our scratch and we end
up with an interesting array this is why
we started doing the for M and match you
can see what's going on in here
we have a pattern we're looking for any
pattern that has a e i o u so the
preceding character it has to be a
character and must contain at least one
of these characters so if one of these
characters are in there then we're gonna
create the pattern or it's going to pull
that match out and we can see here we
end up with apple orange avocado because
each one of them starts with an AE I
over you and then by adding the bound
tags it separates them into words and
let me show you what that looks like
this the best understand how the
boundary tags work let's just remove the
boundaries let's run it without the
boundaries and see what happens and we
run it without the boundaries we end up
with apple banana orange each avocado
Aries so it doesn't care that there's no
letters involved in there and if we do
just the last boundary this is always
fun to do play with this you'll see that
the now keeps the boundary on the right
hand side so it says hey there's a line
return here there's some kind of
beginning or end and of course if we put
the original boundary back in at the
front and run it we end up with apple
orange avocado so we're looking for
those that begin with AEIOU now as much
as I like my fruit you know my apples
oranges and cherries let's look at some
data that we can actually more apt to
apply this to instead of just fruit
let's say we're going through we're
looking for email so we get a little bit
more advanced we have a list of
information that came in maybe you've
scraped this off of a web page and now
you want to find out which one of these
is an email and if you look at it as a
human we can easily see that we have a
string an @ symbol in this case
gmail.com and that represents an email
and we go down here we have another one
which is tiga charm 56 H at hotmail.com
that's probably an email we go down here
to HF G 1 2 3 H at AOL let's missing
like the dot-com so this is not a valid
email and then obviously this is the
last one has no validity to as an email
in any form so what is that pattern like
how do we generate that pattern for this
we're going to do a totally different
series here we're gonna look for a to Z
plus 0 to 9 so it has to start with an A
to Z but they could have a number after
it they could also have B followed by a
to Z and if you notice we're actually
dealing with all lowercase right now
obviously do an uppercase also here a to
z capital a to capital Z so we're
looking at that it has to start with a
letter cuz that's a valid email starts
with a letter and then it can have all
kinds of numbers in there it could have
Y you know kind of a wild character
going on in there a tizzy unknown number
of characters so it represents the wild
characters on there the plus sign just
says we're starting with an A to Z
going to have an @ symbol then also A to
Z plus SKU period calm so it's going to
end with the dot-com that's how we're
gonna read this and this when we send
this in there even though the string
itself we're sending has no escape
characters but as still as far as a
pattern recognition this is going to be
for the re an escape character that says
hey this period is part of what we're
looking for so just like your regular
string you can use it to represent in
here the actual character if it is
already being used as one of the regular
expression characters and we go down
here we go ahead and run this you take
this and run it scratch - we end up with
the two emails that we said we're
probably emails so again this is a great
way to scrape a web page and you can see
that we can pull the emails off of that
scraping or whatever strange a string we
got coming in now at this point if
you're scraping web pages you might need
to find markers on the web page and know
what's going on a little deeper so we're
gonna do find enter for iterate we're
gonna find the iteration and you know
what let's go ahead and do this for em
and match yeah there we go and let's go
ahead and run this and see what this
shows and again this is show us a lot
more information that's what the fine
inter means or fine iterate and you can
see it returns down here instead of just
returning the emails we're looking for
it also says hey this email span from 1
to 16 so here we go 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 and then 15 always includes
there when you're looking at these
things and you see 1 2 16 that means the
placeholders at 1 and the in character
is at 15 that's always important to
remember on that and then we have our
match it shows you what the actual
matches that comes out and the same
thing with the second one it goes
through 27 up to 51 and again we have
the match and the actual email is
showing so you get more information if
you're tracking where is coming out of
these documents and stuff like that that
you're scraping off the web or where
we're pulling these emails this is what
the span is and if we wanted the just
the span we could change this to MDOT
span brackets and if we run this you'll
see we get the 1 16 the 2751 so it just
gives us a location
and of course you could also do em match
we can run that and this is interesting
because they expect you to either do the
match and find all so you can't actually
do an m dot match it's only valid for
the span there we go run that and you
again you can see that one sixteen
twenty seven fifty so let's get out of
the emails that was kind of fun let's
give a new set of data in this case we
have Sam car two four five three Alexa
John ninety and we notice we have a
capital S for Sam and a capital J and a
capital A and then cars and lowercase
either the number two four five three
and let's say you're working on a
project where you've been asked not to
find the names of the people you're
doing word count so you got to remove
all the proper names out so let's say we
want to get rid of the names in here
well the pattern for that again we have
our breaks on each end a tizzy a to Z
and the plus sign we're gonna do here
I'm going to use sub replace anything is
not in the pattern with an empty set so
this stands for substitute and we'll
change this to in string just for sake
of make it easier to read sometimes we
do that let's go ahead and print out our
end string and let's see what this
prints out on here we're gonna run it
there we go
and if we come down to the run window
just split the window up a little bit
we'll see we still have car cuz it
doesn't have a capitalized first letter
we've removed Sam Alexa and Shawn so
we've substituted that with a null value
so they're still here but they just no
longer have any letters in the string
that's what the substitute does it's a
quick way to sort out the names on a
like I said you have a document you're
trying to tokenize it but you don't want
to count names because they're proper
names or maybe you're doing the opposite
you want to pull the names out and do it
the other way either way you can see you
know this is a useful tool for really
digging in deep and finding the patterns
in your strings and pulling that
information out of whatever document
you're working on this concludes our
regular expressions again thank you for
joining us today
we're simply learned as w-w-w comm get
certified get ahead if you have any
further questions feel free to post them
down below
the YouTube questions or come visit us
on our website where we'll be happy to
help you happy learning and have a great
day
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here